Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking it on Ya.
I'm checking in on you
because I give a fuck. Right.
I care about you. Oh, who's the
freckled content gives a fuck.
I do. Um, how's your week going?
Everything going good with you.
I hope it is. Um, oh freckles.
The pasty old fucking man.
48 years old.
My back feels better than it has since
that since I don't know when, um,
just been going to the chiropractor and
get in this fucking the shit beat out of
me in a massage. This
is finally a, I dunno,
it's fucking great.
I guess my spine was compressed
and twisted that for,
for decades. So, you know,
after having professionals beat the shit
out of me for like weekly for like the
last since May, I guess. Um,
I dunno. I think I finally,
I undid, they undid it or whatever.
But now, like when I go to stretch,
when I go to a, you know,
you know the whole thing,
you lay on your back and this young people
won't know this because they just get
up off the couch and start running.
They're fine because they're young,
but old people, you know that
she lay on the floor, right?
You get down on the floor, right?
You make that noise and you keep
going down and getting up.
It's the same noise. Ah, right.
You get down on the fucking ground and
then you bring one of your knees up to
your chest,
right?
And then you bring it over to one side
and then you have your arms sticking up.
You know,
like almost like you're doing like some
sort of old timey football move right.
High stepping over somebody.
But when I do that on the ground now,
I just bring that over in my back.
Just cracks from the lower back to
about three quarters of the way up.
And that never used to,
I wouldn't crack at all.
It was just all fucking jammed in there.
And um,
I feel good man.
I've been working out,
I won't spend eating like a fucking
animal though. Went to a barbecue Sunday,
so that's all she wrote with
that. Right. And I did a show,
so ate barbecue and then I also fucking
eight in a comedy club, Green Room.
And I was working down there
and how most at the, uh,
the comedy and Magic Club and um,
which is really fucking cool to go down
there now because whenever I look at the
pier, I'm like, that's the
thing I fly over. Right? But
you know, as I'm coming down,
you know,
there's the,
the hormone [inaudible] beach pier
and then Manhattan Beach Pier.
When you get to that one, you gotta
be down around like, you know,
like 300 feet. And that's when
you call lax and say, Hey,
I want to fucking skedaddles underneath
the fucking jets there. Right.
And I never knew what any of that shit. I
didn't have a new way. The beaches where
this redheaded cutting,
where the beaches are.
The only reason why I know where the
beaches are is so I know how to drive in
the opposite direction.
I fucking hate the beach.
I fucking,
oh my God,
I hate the beach.
I love the fucking beautiful brown
people that go there, you know,
10 and themselves up. God bless you. I
sit there like the boy in the bubble,
you know,
and one of those Ford Astros with the
slide and fucking door with the AC on
looking out like the boy in
the bubble. Right? Um, I,
I fucking hate it. I get there.
It's hot as fuck. It's boring.
I'm terrified to go in the ocean.
I'm not fucking going in there.
It's Goddamn sea monsters and
they're going to fucking grab you.
You know what? A bunch of 80, we're
kind of a fucking moron. I just,
I'll never get over there at the fact that
people just swim in the fucking ocean.
And Ella was a shark attack
today. Yeah. You know, it's funny.
Somebody goes to the fucking zoo and they,
they crawl into the fucking
cage and he'd get attacked.
Everybody's general consensus.
Consensus is yes, it's a tragedy. And
what'd you think was going to happen?
You know,
you go to the beach and you
go into the fucking ocean,
everybody acts like it's a big city.
Like it's a big surprise.
How did that happen?
I can't believe it.
You went into an unnatural environment,
right?
And it's something where there was a
bunch of shit there that could kill you in
something. Did or took a chunk out
of you, took a fucking bite Audi,
if you know when you've come stumbling
out of there. I don't know why.
It just makes me think of an unfinished,
the Gar when somebody gets bit right.
You know what? I went to
this fucking party, right?
And I brought in Sony for my birthday,
had got me this really
incredible box of cigars.
So I,
uh,
I immediately call all my friends
because, you know, or whatever. It's like,
because I'm not going to smoke all 10
of these fucking things. First of all,
that's not what cigar smoking. It's about.
It's a social thing, right? And secondly,
I don't want to smoke all of them because
I'm trying to keep the habit at bay.
All right. Special occasions
once to twice a month. Right?
So I brought it over there and there
was a bunch of hover and [inaudible] who
all showed up.
Everybody acting like they're fucking
cigar smokers and some handing them out to
these people,
I don't fucking know.
And I turned my back and
like 15 minutes later,
like three of them had been stomped out.
They like, they weren't even halfway done
fucking idiots anyway. So then
I just, I figured that's, yeah,
you get bit by a shark. You know,
he'd come in, it takes like, you know,
the bottom 30 you off and
you come out like a, like a
fucking unfinished. The gar.
No, I don't fucking know. It made sense
to me visually. That's what I thought of.
They're not all going to beat Jess.
Relax. This podcast doesn't even count.
This is me just checking in on
you. Oh, Billy back brace. Huh?
I took it off like fucking Forrest Gump.
I actually feel like I could run,
the only downside to my back feeling as
great as it does right now is I have to
fight myself from doing
something really stupid. Um,
but uh, but has always, I was psyched.
I didn't have to use any drugs.
I stayed away from all of that shit.
And it reminded me of that guy
when I used to watch that doc,
the doctor drew show,
the celebrity Rehab,
and there was that guy from taxi who since
passed away and he kind of got hooked
on painkillers and shit. He's
always bitch about his back. And a,
I remember I had, for whatever reason,
I was just thinking about that. Go, man,
I wish that guy went to a
fucking chiropractor, Mizzou.
So instead of going down the fucking
painkiller route, I don't know. Who knows?
He might have fucking done heroin first.
He might have fucked up
his back nod off on heroin,
although they tend to
stand pretty upright there,
but he keeps it back straight and
then their legs bent. I don't know.
But as always, I don't know what
the fuck's going on. Um, yeah.
So Monday night, Sunday night,
sorry, I went to, uh, went
to the comedy Magic Club,
uh, worked. And that's not an easy
road. It's not an easy room to do. Well,
and as those people have seen a
ton of fucking comedy, you know,
Jay Leno goes down there every Sunday so
they used to seeing the top notch shit.
So you know, if you go down there and
you have fast that you've got a bomb.
So it had,
I had a good set.
Fortunately I had something in
the middle of my set though I was,
I was leaning on the mic stand
and they had, and I had my,
my arm sorta like instead of
leaning on to how I usually do,
I had my arm up and something
was like pushing into my elbow.
And when my hand was like that,
I went to close my make a
fist and like my middle,
my index and my fucking
bring finger wouldn't close.
It was like in slow motion
really freaked me out.
I don't know what the Hell I did, but
what I'm basically telling you, people's,
I'm falling apart. Um, but my
back feels good. So anyways,
so that was the first night
of me and like an asshole.
But I still work out every day
fucking crushing the elliptical.
I give it back at night,
a little bit fucking drink
here are fucking cheese stick,
whatever the fuck I have. Right?
But uh, then Monday last second,
a buddy of mine called me up and said,
hey,
sting and Peter Gabriel a playing at
the fucking Hollywood bull, right?
So I said, you know what, I bet
Vinnie call the UDAs playing drums.
I got to go see that.
That's like a bucket list.
He's one of my favorite
drummers of all fucking time.
And he's one of those guys
who just keeps getting better.
He's an absolute monster.
I mean,
the guy's like pushing 60 years old
and he could still like blow away young
drummers in the teens. You know what I
mean? A lot of young drummers just think,
you know, all the young guys are the
shit and they're all fucking flashy.
And then as guys get older, you know,
they stopped practicing or whatever.
He's one of the few fucking guys,
there was no dropoff.
He just kept getting better and better
and better and better. So I say,
fuck this, right? So I
called up somebody, you know,
who was in the know and I was like,
Hey, is Vinny playing tonight?
And they were like, they got back to
me and I was like, fuck, that was the,
that was the game right there. I was
like, I gotta go fucking see it, right?
So I go on the, uh, the hub of
the stub there, the old stub hub,
and just pay through the fucking nose,
get as close as I can.
So now I'm all fucking excited.
I'm all down low, right?
And I'm fucking going, oh my God. You look
at, they've got to drum kits up there.
I'm guessing Peter Gabriel's
going to open. Do is set,
then stings going to do with
fucking set. And then, uh,
in the end they're going to come out
and sing fucking Hava, Nagila, whatever.
They're gonna do some sort
of encore together, right?
The fucking show starts. Okay. And
there was so many fucking people on stage.
I didn't know what was going on.
And Peter Gabriel all of a sudden is like,
yeah,
you guys like right in front of us.
He sings one of his fucking, I dunno,
world music songs. It was amazing. And
his voice sounded fucking incredible.
And I'm like, okay, the Peter
Gabriel and his giant band here,
this giant ass fucking band,
but two drummers and shit is,
is going to fucking open and then
stinks going to come out and,
and get to see Vinny, right? He
finishes the first fucking song.
He walks offstage and then all
of a sudden sting just walks out.
Everybody's like, what the fuck?
Right? And he starts playing the AFI.
Amba you right. He starts
singing that song and I'm like,
wait a minute,
wait a fucks Vinny.
I realize he's been playing the whole
fucking time. He's just behind these,
this fight. I don't the fuck it
was somebody amps or some shit.
So I could see was like
the top of his head.
But there was like
video screens and stuff.
So of course I was standing
on my tiptoes to watch it,
but what killed me about his
playing is, uh, you know,
every great musician has a voice, right?
I know this is like hacky to say that,
but that fucking guy,
the bell of his ride cymbal and when
he plays the cross stick on his snare,
it's just undeniable. You're like,
that's fucking Vinny [inaudible].
And the fact that I would,
he was making that noise that close to
me and I was immediately hearing it and
just all the Times that I've listened to,
uh,
all the music that he's made
with staying in everybody else,
the fact that they were actually
reproducing it live right there,
it was fucking nuts to me. You know,
like their plan, this, the songs for us,
this is fucking incredible,
right?
So then the consequences and they just
keep flip flopping back and forth.
So stink finished his fucking song.
And then Peter Gabriel came back out,
but staying stayed
in fucking played bass on Peter's shit.
And then he,
they just kept going back and forth.
Then occasionally Peter did too.
And then staying do a couple,
only sting would walk off and Peter
would do his thing and then vice versa,
whatever, and filing in
the middle of it. Um, oh,
maybe towards the beginning.
And I can't, they,
they talked to the crowd a couple times
and they basically said that they were
just that a,
they both had bands and they're kind
of competing with each other band.
And Peter Gabriel's band was the red
band and strings was the blue band.
And then I, then I finally noticed
cell one drummer's got red,
the other Vinnie's playing on
blue drums. And I, you know,
the way he told the story,
they would just, you know,
having battle of the bands and they were
like, why don't we fucking go on tour?
All I can say is,
it was an incredible night.
They played like all the fucking hits.
Peter Gabriel played big time
sledgehammer of shocked, a monkey,
a red rain, uh, staying played, fucking,
uh, sending out. And it's
so as a bunch of shit off.
10 Summers tails,
uh,
some shit off a sole cages. It was some
police stuff. It was fucking amazing.
It was fucking amazing. And, uh, you
know, definitely a bucket list night.
But of course I was in the
crowd and at the Hollywood bowl,
the either drink wine,
which just gives me a brutal hangover oil.
They had these giant fucking beers.
Um,
which I gotta be honest with just does
nothing to me. It's just this, it's like,
it's like somebody just handed a job here,
why don't you drink this? Like, yeah,
fuck. And I get it. I get
really nothing out of it.
It's why I like Whiskey, you know,
it gives you the right there Fred,
and it's just a couple of
swallows. Um, but anyways,
Jesus Christ, the level of
musicianship, the backup singers,
one in particular was just, they kept,
you know, given her solos and stuff,
she was incredible. Um, got
to watch stink, played bass,
got to watch them up close.
And the weird way he kind of comes
from the side rather than might've.
Bass players are kind of have their hand
up top rest of their thumb on the low e
or whatever the fuck that string is.
And he's,
he looks like he's coming at it
from the side, like a fucking crab.
It was really interesting.
But uh, anyways,
it was like some of the best
musicians you ever going to see.
So that's what I did Monday.
And uh, then Tuesday we came in,
we did the Polish up after the table read
of episode 10 and we recorded episode
10, and that's it. Oh,
fucking Billy red faces on
fucking a summer vacation here.
Then I got a nice, um, I
don't know where I got,
I got about nine days before I go off to
the European tour and I'm going to work
out like a madman still, you know, have
a couple, two, three drinks, whatever.
It work hard, play hard. What are you
gonna do? And I plan to have a nice,
um, I want to have a healthy
fucking tour over there.
You know,
my wife isn't going on this run.
She's going to meet me
over there afterwards,
when to take a few days to hang out. But
uh, during the whole run, it's a thrash.
It's like a different
city every fucking night.
So it's kind of boring and pointless.
You're really just saying to the
person who isn't doing shows like, Hey,
do you want to,
uh,
do you want to go over to Europe and
like pack and unpack every fucking day?
And they're like, yeah, no, I
don't in barely see anything.
That's what I'm offering you. So
what I want to do, the first died,
I'm working with Joe to Rosa in Dublin on
one of the shows. It's an earlier show,
which is odd to me, but whatever.
It's not my fucking deal. Right?
So that night's a wash. I mean,
we're going to get shit faced. Um,
then the next night I'm in Belfast and
I got to drive up and drive back so that
night I'll fucking take it easy. The
Irish people bitching. I already asked,
stop being a pussy drink every night.
I can't do it cause I got to make sure I
have good shows. And then I got Gallway.
But a chill for that,
that London chill for the first night.
Second night I'm going to maybe,
you know,
knock a few back and then I go
to Scotland, I believe. And,
uh, two nights stair. I'll just fucking
chill. And then the third night,
you know, that's going to be hard
because it's, it's the whole fucking,
the festivals going on over there.
Somebody, me being a ton of Comedians,
that might be a rough one. And then
Jeremy, I don't gotta worry about Shit.
Who's kidding? Who? I got to go out
and have some beers that you, okay.
It's going to get a little rough
and once I get around Scotland,
who's kidding who but, but
the, the first half of it. Aw,
that first half I'm going to be healthy.
Um,
does Amsterdam in there?
All right. You know what?
This whole thing just went off the rails.
Okay.
For the first few nights in Ireland,
I think it's going to be okay one
night in London. Other than that, yeah,
it might be a little rough,
but if I can eat well,
yeah.
The problem is when you go over to Europe
though, there's just this, just fuck it.
There's no treadmills. They, these
people just don't work out. It's weird.
They're not like necessarily fat,
but they're not in shape either.
They just sort of, people mean,
you know what I mean? Like, yeah,
those are arms, you know? Yeah. They're
connected to your torso. They got
like, I think ellipticals
are illegal in England.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Everybody's so jammed in there and that
little island, um, I'm fucking with you.
Obviously they have gyms over there,
so I'm going to try to hit treadmills
and shit as much as I can. And, uh,
I already know how I'm going to open my
set when I'm over there, you know. Um,
it's, it's going to be, it's
going to be a great fucking time.
I can't wait to do it.
And I'm so site that we got the
first big chunk of work done on a,
on f is for family. I feel I
can, could finally fucking, uh,
can finally fucking chill out and
coming up this week, by the way,
next Monday night is the second,
uh,
the two year anniversary of
the goddamn comedy jam and a,
they're going to have it at the rock
seat down on sunset boulevard. And
rumor has it that I'm,
I might be down there.
I'm going to be down there for that show.
It's next Monday night if
you are in the area and uh,
I'm going to be busting out the fucking,
I'm going to bust out the
fucking green spark a Ludwig Kit.
I'm going to bring it down there for that.
And I bought it two years ago.
I've never played it. I got this
71 Ludwig, it's fucking gorgeous.
And right as I got it,
I had it all set up and everything.
We got what we had the
water damage on the house.
Fortunately thank Christ it didn't come
down in the room where the drums were.
So immediately went out and I got drunk
cases and I put the fucking things away.
And then, um, you know,
that was a year getting the house fixed
and they stayed in cases and then the
next year my truck,
shit,
the bed I had to get the engine rebuilt
because it was going to do is put them
in the cases and take them
over to a rehearsal space.
I was never able to do that at a,
that my truck was better.
And then I started writing
on f is for family.
So and just like that fucking two
years goes by. So I busted them out.
71 Ludwig kick, I got the fucking Pisces
symbols, that whole bottom set up,
the 15 inch high hat, the 24 inch
ride, complete fucking overkill.
And I'm going to play a couple songs.
I actually sat down and played drums
today for the first time since like March,
I played like a drum kit,
you know,
other than a cup that I think I took
two lessons. But that's, you know,
different than sitting down and playing.
And I'll tell you right now,
I fucking inside, oh Jesus, oh, sorry.
Just blew out the uh, you're saying, oh my
God, that was fucking terrible. Terrible.
I better get my shit
together by Monday night.
Or I'm just going to look like a dish
with a really nice kid who can't fucking
play. Um, but I'm really
looking forward to doing that.
And I'll let me do a little,
still read here.
The one advertising advertisement
that we have here for this week,
it's our old friends.
Oh, a little bit of Zip.
Where are you hiding?
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post all you need to post
your job on it, all the top sites,
and now you can with fuck zip.com you
can post jobs to 100 plus job sites
including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with one single click.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip.
They're easy to use. Interface no
juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip right has been
used by over 800,000 businesses and right
now my listeners can post jobs to zip
recruiter Karuna for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/burr that's
ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Yeah.
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] all
right, there you go. Sorry about that.
I fucking thought I had the levels down.
I guess when you scream zip recruiter,
it's bound to go off the
rails after a while. Um,
all right. So what else did I
want to talk about? Anything? Um,
somebody said that the New York Times
did this article and for the love of God,
I can't,
it they did it.
And talking about the legalization of pot
and was saying in states where weed is
become illegal, dep, uh,
prescriptions have gone down drastically,
obviously for pain,
anxiety and all of that other stuff.
And it's really starting to become the
wonder drug man that all the hippies
always said. And I always
fucking was like, no, booze
is legal, blah, blah, blah.
And now it's really looking at like,
booze does way more fucking damaged. Oh.
But it's so delicious. Does way
more damage than we does. So,
according to this New York Times article,
according to this person who said it
was in New York Times article, um,
that the pharmaceutical lobbyists are
now going after legalized marijuana in
every state and then they're going to try
and start trying to fucking, you know,
basically go,
oh my God,
it's the devil in Blahblahblahblahblah
and get people to stop using it and have
all this shit about side effects it,
but they'll start showing commercials
and all that. But I got to tell you, um,
the fact that this is the pro ball,
maybe they won't,
I was gonna say the problem that they're
going to have is now that the cat's out
of the bag,
okay.
In the states are making so
much money in tax revenue,
right? Like this, this whole
thing going on at Denver,
because it's legal at a state level,
but not at a federal level.
You don't pay federal income tax
and it's this weird fucking thing.
So nobody knows. Oh, I know
banks won't accept the money,
you know, cause the banks,
federal banks or whatever,
can't accept the money or whatever.
So what these,
these people who grow the wheat are
doing and they're just buying up land.
So in Colorado, from what I heard,
once again, I never read, I, I,
I listened to people and whatever they
say to me, I just considered it as,
as a fact, right? It's so much
easier than doing research.
And you know what's great about it?
If you fuck up,
it makes other people feel
smart, you know, nothing,
nothing structure Rigo like
correcting another human being.
That's a human being. That thing
can speak. It could drive a car.
Maybe you can fly a plane to be right.
I mean,
anybody can be right when there's a dog,
you know,
there's a fucking dog in the room that
doesn't do anything for you, you know?
But if it's another fucking Parson right,
he's got a thumb and shit and getting
like hold a hammer. If you're fucking Rad,
that just, it's the greatest.
I actually, ah, that was,
it was actually 1897 yes.
1890 set Spanish American war.
Anytime you get to do that and then you
get to watch them be all fucking mad.
Like when I was talking about George Bush,
I thought everybody was making fun of
them cause he deep, he didn't dance well.
I didn't realize it was some
memorial service for, you know,
fallen officers or, or, uh, an officer in
particular. And I didn't, I didn't look,
I just watched the fucking video. Oh. And
it just rolled in, you know, everybody,
oh, let's, let's, let's fucking
correct old Billy red beard. You know,
everybody had a great fucking time doing
that. Um, but I'm off the rails here.
Okay. I still have to say, you know, you
know, as much as that was inappropriate,
which was completely
inappropriate, obviously, it
was fun to see him, you know,
it was fun to see that he's
enjoying his retirement.
It's like when you see Letterman,
he let the beard go out.
He got rid of the fucking two page.
It doesn't, it doesn't give a shit.
And when you look at him, a lot
of people were saying, you know,
maybe George was a little drunk.
And, uh, you know what? Good for him,
good for that fucking guy
because that fucking guy,
he held it together for eight
goddamn years. You know,
granted he gave a speech.
The way I read advertising,
granted we winded and into wire rack
because there was weapons of mass
destruction and we never
fucking found Eddie.
I love all that fucking story goes away.
But if you make fun of
fat people as a comedian,
all of a sudden you get in trouble. And
was like, what about this fucking guy?
This guy here was playing
fucking patty cake,
Patty cake bakers man at a
fucking funeral. Good Lord.
That guy is like, he's like you
when you talk about failing upwards,
I think you know something.
There's something about that guy.
He's just smart enough to
know that he's not qualified.
And I think that that's why he drinks.
I think that's why it's got to hate
that fucking vibe. He just, he,
he's kind of like Rodney, like he does
everything but tugs on his collar.
Like it'll tell you it's a rough
one, you know? Um, I dunno.
We'll see. We'll see. What
the fuck happens. But what
was I talking about? Oh yeah.
In New York Times they were saying that,
you know,
that these pharmaceutical lobbyists, you
know, we're, we're going to be trying to,
you know, fight back to win back some of
their money, capitalistic society here.
Right. What do you do? Somebody taking
India, you're cutting India territory.
What he had done. Yeah.
You go on the offensive,
you start making up shit about him. You
lie, you know, that's what you do. So,
um,
I was going to say now that the cat
is out of the bag legally with weed,
um, and I think it's going to be
really hard. I was going to say,
because not only is it appearing to have
all these positive effects medically
according to stuff that people said to
me that they allegedly said scientists
did. Um, it also makes you feel good.
That's a rough one. You know what I
mean? Whereas all that other shit,
a lot of the pharmaceutical stuff
just sorta like numbs the pain,
all of that stuff.
And then you all of a sudden you get
onto the harder drugs and all that.
It's really fucking evil. You
know, I got a friend of mine,
she had problems with there. She
couldn't some going on with the shoulder.
She couldn't pick a fucking
arms up past shoulder.
I referred it to this same as suits
that I went to and she immediately was
getting results and she,
she was, according to her,
was stuck going to these
fucking doctors. I'm, look,
I'm not totally shitting on doctors
and stuff like that, but, uh,
I don't know.
It would be nice if the mainstream medical
would kind of let these other people
come in. You know what I mean?
It's just that I think the,
the people outside people outside of the
mainstream medical basically hospitals
and shit, I don't know what mainstream
medical means. It just sounds right to me.
Right? Oh Jesus. I am so out of my fucking
element. You know what? It feels good.
I feel like I could start swinging
my arms at a funeral right now. Um,
when you get outside of hospitals
and stuff, you could actually,
most people you'll find,
don't know what the fuck that dude,
but if you find that gem that's outside
of the fucking studio system, basically,
they actually can cure, you know,
where a lot of this other shit is.
Just treating it and treating it and
treating it and treating it until you then
get symptoms for something else and
then treat that, treat that, treat that.
You know, I dunno. It's, it's
a fucking shady think and uh,
it's a big fucking problem and it
requires a lot of reading and research.
And I have to be honest with you,
I did none of that before I started
talking about seven minutes ago.
So there's that subject.
What are we up to here? 27,
almost 28 minutes.
Um,
this is all drawn nerd shit,
but I saw Steve Smith has
playing with journey again.
I'm gonna have to go fucking see that.
You know,
I've never seen him when he
played with vital information.
I've never seen that guy play life. Got
All his fucking DVDs and all that shit.
There's another one I got to check off
the fucking bucket list. But uh, um, if,
if that, that sting Peter Gabriel
tourists coming to your, uh,
neck of the woods, do not sleep on
it. Like I've never seen like staying,
having so much fucking fun and ever,
never realized how like goofy
and silly Peter Gabriel was.
It's got all these sychronized dances
and shit. It's fucking hilarious.
And he's funny as hell and like sting
was just like really just taken a back
seat when letting Peter,
Shane and all of that,
I'll let you know all that fucking drama
that you always heard in that band.
The police, it was great seeing
stink. Just fucking, I mean,
granted the guy's still,
he looks better than he looked
when he was in the police.
It's fucking ridiculous.
Jesus Christ clean living and,
and fucking yoga and whatever the fuck
he does that tantric where you come for
like fucking 50 minutes, whatever that
shit is. It's unbelievable. I mean,
the guy looks better than
he did fucking 30 years ago.
His hair somehow grew back. I, I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck this guy is doing.
He looks like it's a combination of like
a teen idol and he said like Mad Max
all at the same time.
He never kind of would like,
as far as like his wardrobe though,
I will say that guy is never
sort of advanced past um,
uh, that synchronicity tour, you know?
And when he yells, he always has to
put an o at the end of it. You know,
when he did Roxanne and then when he had
wanted to do a call and response with
the crow with the crowd is going
like,
where did they all come
from? He loves the, Oh,
I bet he does that in his castle. You
know, his wife yells up, you know,
up the fucking goddamn stone stairway.
Stay
for lunch, lunch, lunch. And he's
up there. Let's sandwich. Yo,
she's fucking driving her
nuts. Fuck does he put, oh,
at the end of everything just fucking say
sandwich. All right, you fucking cunt.
What? You get knighted and all sudden you
can put an o at the end of everything,
you know. Anyways, what am I doing
here? It was so fucking great show. Um,
all right, so I still have to go to work
tomorrow and how we do the animatics,
I'll take you through the whole process.
Everybody over the next year as we wait
for this fucking thing to come out.
So once you write the thing, and once
you record it, before they animate it,
they had these things called animatics,
which is just rough sketches.
Okay. Of the scenes, the way that they're
going to draw, draw, like, you know,
they look at the script and says,
you know,
frank walks into the house so
they know it's in the house,
but there's a lot of other stuff that
has sort of variables about where people
are standing and where they're sitting,
how they're eyes are moving and
all of that shit. And it's that,
this is where it gets a
little bit tedious. But, uh,
it was much harder the first season,
the second season.
Now everybody kind of knows
how everybody creates and shit.
So we go in now and we'll look at
the animatic for like the second,
first or second episode. And
you just look at, you know,
is the scenes go and you'd be like,
all right,
frank needs to be standing up here or
sue needs to be doing this or whatever.
And um,
I have to be honest with you,
I am decent at arm gestures,
but I'm really bad at the directing shit.
Like this should be a two shot that
should be a master and all that. Um,
not only make bad at it,
I have no desire to get good at it.
So that's a tough thing.
Like I don't give a shit that is that
there's nothing more boring to me then
that just sitting there going like,
this should be over this guy's
shoulder and this should be a two shot.
Can we Dolly in? Can we get
a fucking whatever the fuck
they say. And I just said,
I just glaze over.
It reminds me of when,
for whatever stupid fucking reason,
my junior year of high school,
like
I took Algebra two and
fucking trigonometry and it
was just like I fucking had
to go to summer school after Algebra.
I barely got out of that shit.
I got to fucking d minus in geometry
just because my teacher was cool.
I flunked it.
She gave me the d minus,
so I didn't have back to back going
to summer school and the district,
I mean, I was lost by, I was done. I
was done three weeks into September,
Algebra two and trig.
It was fucking over.
And I ended up in fucking
motherfucking summer school again.
I swear to God, my geometry teacher
didn't hook me up with a d minus.
I would have had like a dynasty.
I would have three years in a row,
a summer school, fucking dope. Um,
I don't know.
I'll tell you this right now.
This is how dumb I am is I can't even
remember why I even just fucking told you
that. What the hell was I talking about?
I just sat up in my whole memory, went,
what the fuck? A hell of his. What right
did I started talking about? I
don't, I don't, I don't remember. Um,
but you know what the great thing is is
I don't have to remember anything else
who gives a shit because this is,
this is the a,
this is just me checking in on you.
Just peeking into your cubicle or maybe
you've got an office. You've got a door.
Huh? You feel good about yourself. You
like that door. He puts stuff audit.
Do you close it and say,
no calls makes you feel good.
Then you close the door and you snicker
to yourself. Like I just said, no calls.
Um,
the no calls guy hold my calls.
Um, anyways. All right, that's
it. That's, that's a podcast. Uh,
please go see Peter Gabriel and
sting on tour and he amazing Vinny,
call euro and everybody else
in both of those bands. Uh,
I should have known more than
names. I should have looked
it up. But, uh, you know,
I'm running around like a fucking
loan to tick. Um, and that's it.
If anybody can find that New York Times
article, I would really love to read it.
And,
um,
I'm also going to try to read up on all
that whole fucking European Union thing
for when I go over there just in
case anybody's a cunt to me, uh,
about not knowing what the fuck's going
on in the world, which, which I don't. Um,
I do know that there was some sort of
fucking failed coup attempt in Turkey.
Jesus Christ. The only thing scarier
than trying to overthrow the,
the government is attempting
it and then failing.
This is one of the scariest
couple of paragraphs I ever read.
Turkey's President Tayyip t double.
Why Ip Ert again,
tell you bird again.
Um,
declared a state of emergency on Wednesday
as he widened a crackdown against
thousands of members of the security
forces judicial to judiciary,
civil service and academia
after a failed military coup.
All right, here's where it gets
scary. Erdogan, however, you said,
said the state of emergency lasting three
months would allow his government to
take swift and decisive measures against
supporters of the COO and was allowed
under the constitution.
Yeah,
they're about to kill a
couple thousand motherfuckers.
Jesus.
That right there is the definition and
the Joe [inaudible] and the old right
there, Fred, right. There's
no cold lotion in there. Okay.
MMM,
you're not cold. Lotion is, is
is your final meal on death row.
Yeah, man. We'll make you whatever you
want. Uh, you guys in sweetheart. Yeah.
And then we're going to electrocute
you. Ah, Jesus. Then. All right. Um,
that's the podcast,
but just checking in on you.
I'll see you guys again on a talk to you.
Get on Monday and um,
that's it.
Thank you to everybody who helped
fix my fucking back. I feel great.
I'm in a great mood.
Please enjoy this music.
And then we got 30 minutes
of some throwback podcasts.
Greatest hits from a podcast in a year.
All right.
See
you soon.
Okay,
so I got that out of the way.
Then I had two days to hang in New York
and then I came down in New Jersey and
I'm like, this is going to be great. I
got the pressure, a Letterman off me.
That's off my fucking
back. And uh, now what?
Now what do I do? I get to go to one
of my favorite clubs in the country.
Okay.
The stress factory. I was already talking
to what Vinnie brand? The club owner.
He's got a boat. We were going
to go out on his boat on Sunday.
Everything was going to be great.
All the shows were fucking sold up.
Had a great time and then what happens?
These fucking nerds on the
weather channel. What do they do?
They turn out all the lights in their
studio and they put a flashlight under
their Chin
and just start scaring the living shit
out of people and you know what kills me
is every fucking time people buy into it.
I was joking about it all weekend.
I'm like, nothing's going to happen.
I am in my hotel. Tell them I don't
even have a fucking snickers bar.
Nothing's going to happen.
You're going to be fine.
All these people going out
gathering up fucking food for what
people do. You realize how long you can
go without food. Food is no big deal.
You need water. That's what the
fuck you need. That's what you need.
I'm actually looking here on a,
who gives a fuck.com?
How long can a person survive
without food and water? Uh,
basically it depends on a number
of factors such as bodyweight,
genetic variations, other
health considerations, whether
you're a fat fuck or not.
Uh, most importantly, the presence
or absence of dehydration.
As long as you got water people,
you can basically go 46
to about 73 days without,
without food.
Then that was based on a 10 individuals
who died on a hunger strike and they all
died between 46 days and 73 days.
As long as they drank water.
If you don't have water, I believe
you dead. And about three days.
All right,
so enough with the fucking milk and eggs,
all the soccer moms now for the
next fucking three weeks. Who wants,
who went theorial?
Who wants what you have in theory?
Alanya having an Omelette
isn't going to go to waste.
He's fucking people telling you to fill
up your goddamn bathtub full of full of
full of water just in case
Jesus fucking Christ. I'd rather
die than drink out of my bathtub.
All right.
I wash my fucking dog in there,
not drinking out of that thing.
What can I just stick my head out
the window and drink? The rain drops.
I think those when those be cleaner than
the God damn tub that I watched my dog
in and then hit with chemicals,
love stomach cancer.
By the time to fucking rescue boat comes,
you just get water.
Everybody get water.
Get yourself a couple of fucking zag
nut bars and they'd go down, go down,
go down to a god bad in fucking
seven 11 and go buy an $8 Poncho.
You find you were in a house,
you fine.
It's fucking people or whether
she know how much they cost me.
Half my God Damn Gig money.
We could've had shows we
could add show Saturday night.
It was raining hard Saturday night.
It could have done both shows.
Everybody could have
got their fucking labs.
Everybody goes home and then
at night [inaudible] Boegli
the fucking hurricane. Hurricanes come
through the north east. It's like,
it's like an old price fighter.
By the time it comes to us,
it's all fucking punch drunk and people
have no business standing out in it
cause they should've got knocked out,
have no fucking problem.
Then they just sit there laughing
at it. All right. That's what it is.
That's what a hurricane is
in the northeast. It, you
know when it's down south,
it's Cassius clay.
Right before he becomes Muhammad Ali,
by the time it gets up to Jersey
in New York, it's fucking Ali.
When he fought Larry
Holmes every fucking time.
Yet these people,
they all run out
the weather channel.
How long you guys,
you guys think Fox News
lies to you or CNN?
Depending on what side of the
political fence you're on, you want it.
You want to see some lies
put on the weather channel.
Anytime there's a storm
scaring the shit out of you,
every time there's going to be,
it's going to be four to six edge says,
Holy Shit,
that's almost up to my calves.
How will I ever get to where the food is?
46 inches. Jesus Christ.
Who are they talking to?
80 year olds.
Okay.
Even then, you know, 80 year old
people, they'll be fine. You are there.
They're already wearing a sweater.
Okay.
They're dressed for a blizzard year round.
Does anybody will work
for the weather channel?
Does anybody who listened to my
podcast, can you please tell me? Well,
who's behind you? I think the
supermarkets have behind that, right?
Ralph's Shaws,
Gelson's fucking whole foods.
All of them. That's their payola.
You know, with a big time corporations,
they wait for the political elections.
That's when they start throwing their
money around and start calling up a truck
full of hookers to go blow some
Bible belt and Douche bag. Right?
Oh, married. I got five kids. I love my
wife and I love Jesus. Support the troops.
Right? And then what do they
do? They throw a big pile
of money at them. Have two,
three horse drop to their knees. And
next what? Next? What happens next? Huh?
He comes on his blue blazer.
That's what happens.
Everybody goes all over his red tie
and then he goes, AH, Jesus Christ.
All right, you got me, you
own me. You got video of it.
Just tell me what you want me to do.
I will pass any bill you want
me to pass for the love of God.
Don't let my wife see that.
Okay.
That's basically how that works. Well,
let's, let's stay on track here. Okay.
The fucking weather. Does anybody listen
to my podcast work? Did they ever work?
Can you give me any sort of anonymous
behind the fucking scenes over there? Why?
Every time it's just going to rain.
Okay.
Did they scare the living shit out of us?
Why is that?
You know,
how often are they right?
It always is.
It's always downgraded to a tropical
storm. By the time it comes here,
someone was telling me the entire
east coast, the way it's shaped,
that's from years of hurricanes
comes right into Florida and Georgia.
South Carolina gives it a nice fucking
upper cut to their southern balls and
then slows the fuck down right
over the Carolina, Virginia.
Yep.
Then what?
Trimet,
it hits DC.
Barack Obama's out on the porch
drying off his nuts with those. Nice.
That nice hurricane when,
right. Oh Jesus. I don't know.
I'm talking about, I just want to
fucking go home. I was actually thinking,
you know, when you, you, you know, when
you fuck up in life, feel like God,
if I could just go back 48 hours,
Howard do this differently.
There's an Avis in the lobby of my,
uh,
you know Jesus as a callback. I remember
this time we left this comedian,
he was always late.
We had a car service to the airport.
We were so sick of waiting for when
we were going to miss our flight.
We just took off with
that and we said fuck him.
And we got halfway to the airport and he
calls up all pissed off. It's like, Yo,
where the fuck boy you put a fuck.
Why are you like do we waited for
your 20 minutes? You didn't show up?
And he's like,
I was in the,
and that became the catch
phrase for the rest of the tour.
I was in the lobby anytime you
fucked up and people will call him,
calling you on some shit. You went over
your time. No I didn't. Yes you did.
I was in the lobby.
Oh.
And it made us laugh. I don't know if
it made you laugh. I don't give a shit,
but he expected from
me. I'm, I'm stranded.
I feel like I'm being held hostage in
my captors. Forgot about me, you know?
And maybe it was just all a practical
joke. I have no idea. So whatever.
Here I sit.
Okay.
You know, it was anything sadder than a
stranded comedian with no shows to do.
Yeah.
They got a 24 hour gym downstairs.
I haven't used it.
Okay.
Um, but talking to you guys about all
the way to eat, the way you lose weight.
I haven't been doing it dummy pizzas.
I had fish and chips today.
I had fucking to hamburgers.
This is all during a hurricane,
big bad hurricane Irene
fucking over rated.
So I'm sitting here, I realized,
you know, tomorrow I'm like,
finally I'm getting the fuck out of
here. Go home. Could see my girl,
I can see my dog.
Right?
Can I have a good fucking time,
you know,
can cruise around in my hybrid.
That's what I was looking
forward to doing. And, uh,
all of a sudden I realized that
was stranded here. So what do I do?
Do I handle it like a man? What do
I start cursing like a little bitch?
You know what the answer is? So once I'm
done having my fucking temper Tantrum,
excuse me, I a sufficient
chips. I say, all right,
I'm going to run a fucking
rent a movie here in the hotel.
So I go to rent a movie.
It's called catching hell to documentary
about the guy with the glasses who was
at the cubs game, who, uh,
reached up for that foul ball that
Moisis Lou was allegedly going to catch.
So I hit the info to watch the
trailer and they're talking about,
they got this guy on,
they're gone and says how he worked for
sports illustrated and his assignment
was to find this guy.
Okay,
whatever the fuck his name was,
Steve [inaudible]. I don't know.
I'm not from Chicago, so I don't give
a shit. I don't know what his name is.
All right. His, as he goes, my assignment
was to find this guy and he goes,
my heart sank. You know, because
I actually felt for this guy,
I didn't want to go see him.
And I said to my editor, editor,
why can't we just leave this guy alone?
Can't we just leave the guy alone?
He goes, no, go find them. And then they
shout showing the highlights of this dude.
And for those of you don't know the play,
basically the cubs have won the
world series since 1908. You know,
there a game away from going there,
five outs away from going to the fucking
world series. Sorry to all the cub fans.
Just hit fucking mute for
the next 10 minutes. Um,
okay.
They got the five outs
away. So some dude, right?
A lefthanded batter hits a slicing
foul down the left field line.
It's right there.
And uh,
the cubs left field or Moises Alou, he's
got a chance to make a play and all the,
all these fans reach up to
grab the ball. But the, the,
it just hits one guy and a Moises Alou
flips out cause he doesn't catch it and
he sorta yells towards the fans. Like,
what the fuck I could've caught that.
And then after that the
wheels start falling off,
but they got a double play ball.
Good solace could have made it.
Buddy booted it man first and
then they let up eight runs,
they lose the game and
then they lose game seven.
And then everybody wants
to murder this fucking kid.
So this guy is basically sold that.
They're going to basically interview
the guys far as I could fucking tell.
And I'm like, Jesus Christ,
that's fascinating. I want
to let me watch this. God,
God knows I got the time.
Let me watch this movie.
All right, so I go to order
it and it doesn't allow me to,
so I got to call downstairs
to have the uh, you know,
I dunno what somebody had kids or
something. I didn't want to run a porno,
so I had to get that,
you know,
just switched over so I could actually
be an adult and pick out a movie.
So I watched this fucking thing.
All right. About the cubs,
about their history,
about their curse,
about this poor bastard that
got used as the scapegoat.
This is what I was sold. This is
the bill of goods. I was sold.
Okay. After 36 hours of being lied
to by the fucking weather channel,
I want some truth in my life. This is what
you're telling me. This thing is about,
this is how your advertising
and I want to see it.
Do you know what the first
15 minutes of that movie was?
It was taking me through the red sox
in 1986 as they excrutiatingly slowly
replayed the bill Buckner incident
and I'm sitting there watching it.
All of a sudden I'm looking
at bill Buckner. I'm like,
what the F did I order the wrong
fucking thing? I don't want to see shit.
Do you understand? This is like my
baseball nine 11 I don't ever want it.
You know that like the 10 year anniversary
of of nine 11 is coming up and like
they,
I don't want to watch any of that.
I don't ever want to
see that footage again.
Like how the fuck could you ever forget
it? It's absolutely fucking horrific.
Horrific.
I don't want to see it.
I don't need to see it to remember it.
I'll never forget. It's our Pearl Harbor.
My grandmother still doesn't like
Japanese people because of Pearl Harbor.
Okay. If she can remember that
shit, I don't think I got a problem.
Remember something 10 fucking
years ago. Okay, so now. Anyways,
total total fucking tangent there.
So I'm watching this thing and for the
first 20 just to worn red sox fucking
fence,
the first fucking 15 minutes of this
movie is the bill Buckner thing.
The thing that we left behind.
It's so funny because Paul Versey just
texted me then the night before during
the hurricane,
typical fucking Yankee Fed,
typical Yankee Fan living in the
past, right? He, he texted me,
he goes, hey bill, what was, what
was worse for a Red Sox Fan? He goes,
Buckner or Aaron Boone
just out of nowhere,
we won't even talk in baseball.
And I was just like,
I was like neither do to it.
It's like,
I don't even think about that shit
anymore to be honest with you.
And then he gets mad at me about a typical
red sox fan. Terrible fucking answer,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. It's like,
I don't know what he wanted out of me,
so I just texted back. It's like, dude,
I haven't thought about that shit since
2004 it's over. You know what it is.
It's Yankee fans used to be able to bully
red sox fans about that shit because
we hadn't won one forever, you know?
So they just, I think that they,
they miss,
they're kind of like our big brother who
just beat the shit out of us forever.
And then one day we were the same height
and kick the shit out of him, you know?
And then they just, they, it was
over. We're not scary anymore.
We expect to beat you.
It's fucking over. And I,
I think they still don't know what to do.
You know?
Wait a minute, we used to tease you
and we used to always win and yeah,
now you don't,
now you don't.
Now we got this the biggest choke of all
fucking time as hung around your neck.
That will never be beaten.
When do you guys think another
$220 million $10 million team,
whatever the fuck it was with five first
ballot hall of famers are going to lose
four games in a row,
have to be an up three games to none.
I'm asking you to a fucking team that
hasn't won a world series and like a
hundred years.
Right.
He had just asked me about that and I
swear to God I had not thought about
Buckner.
Yeah,
yeah. Since like all for it was
fucking, it was over. It was great.
I don't even give a shit now. I don't
even give a shit. And I got to tell you,
it's phenomenal to sit down and watch
a red sox game and something good to
happen.
And when something bad happens,
you get upset at the player rather than
some sort of specter or some sort of
ghost or some overly boogaloo horse shit.
Right?
So
I'm going to watch this fucking thing.
And all of a sudden out of nowhere,
this show, and I may do, they broke.
They almost broke down bill Buckner more
than they broke down this poor cubs fan.
Yeah.
And in the end the dude doesn't get
the interview. There's no interview.
They just talk all day.
But what I still recommend it,
I'm still wrecking recommending
it because they show,
um,
they talk to the people.
Some people, I guess they found the
people who like through bear Adam,
they talked to the security guard.
He was removing them,
giving them shit that he now feels bad
that he did and they have the footage of
him going out of the ballpark
and putting the jacket over him.
It's fucking amazing what
happens to this dude.
And uh, I, I totally
recommend it, but I just,
they should have been some sort
of warning for a red sox fan.
It was like walking,
go run in into your old psycho girlfriend.
Okay.
Somebody who stopped you or something.
Just somebody who just hadn't even
thought about 2000 for seven years.
I haven't thought about that shit.
I haven't even thought about that.
And fucking seven years. And all of a
sudden this documentary about the cubs,
they just go blow by blow
through the Buckner thing.
Cause I guess they wanted to show
how Buckner was used as escape goat,
despite the fact Bob Stanley through the
wild pitch and how this kid was used as,
as the goat for the cubs,
despite the fact that Gonzales
booted a fucking double play ball,
which would've got him out
of the [inaudible]. Um,
okay.
I Dunno, it's, I, it's
definitely interesting, but
I was, I was more than upset
that and an elder and they even
show the Aaron Boone home run,
which I don't even remember because
that was basically annoying for about 12
months,
you know,
because it was immediately rectified
and,
uh,
but it was just one of those things.
I don't know. I don't fucking know,
but I gotta be honest with you,
I never really felt bad for cubs fans.
I never did because, you know, they
didn't have that anger did the Midwest,
I don't know what it is. They're
positive. I don't know what it is.
They just didn't have
that anger or misery.
Okay.
You know what? The Red
Sox, back in the day,
it was every Yankee success was
our failure. And with the cubs,
they just, you know, hey,
let's play two zip Betty do.
Du was like a big fucking keg party,
you know.
It's like they didn't even give a shit.
Even their curse was stupid.
The curse of the goat.
It was just fucking stupid.
MMM.
Made no sense. It's a ballpark. You've
got a goat. It doesn't belong here.
It's going to shit all over the place.
Get it Outta here. I curse you. Really?
MMM.
Any fucking waste. So they actually
bring up what, like skateboarding,
my sheet ruining this entire thing.
You probably don't have to fucking run it.
They start talking about what? It's,
how they came up with that terminology.
The scape goat and it went
back to religion. Oh Gee.
That I guess back in the day, I don't
know what the hell religion it was.
They're all fucking stupid when you really
get down to it other than they're due
on to other stuff that every religion has.
Um,
they would basically have a goat.
They bring a goat in and I'm thinking,
all right, they're going to sacrifice
it or whatever, and they wouldn't have,
the priest would lay his hands on a goat
for once instead of some unsuspecting
child.
Oh, a little molestation joke for
ya. How'd you guys like that? Huh?
Do you like that on your Monday? Do you
think that that was crossing the line?
Well, fuck you. I'm
stranded in New Jersey.
Okay.
Fucking New Jersey, Huh? Jesus
Christ. What? A bunch of animals.
You know what amazes me about New Jersey
is how they still support Jon boat.
Jon Bon Jovi or the Bon Jovi bend to the
point that that band can sell out giant
stadium
still.
Okay.
Unbelieve let's Jersey for it's
70,000 people singing, singing along.
Lay Your hands on me.
Your love is not bad.
Med is to [inaudible].
Whoa.
Fucking acid wash as far as
the eye can see, dirty jersey.
Actually, I think New Jersey underrated
is New Jersey. It's fucking phenomenal.
All these New York snobs,
Paul Versey being one of them.
I'm really trashing him this week.
Paul versus your typical New York snob.
And I hope you're listening
to this, Paul, our help born,
somebody sends this to you. Um, yeah,
he's,
he's a snob.
He's one of those guys who just thinks
because he's on the other side of an
imaginary line that all of a sudden,
I don't know what that the
trees are greener. The grass is,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
You know what I really realize,
like most New Yorkers judge New Jersey
on their drive to Newark Airport where
they go by all those chemical plants,
look at it. It's so fucking shit hole. Oh,
right.
Despite the fact that all some of
the most major celebrities live here,
we think they live next to the plant.
You know,
all those fucking guys down on Wall
Street, the children of the Illuminati,
they all live out there. And
Red Bank with their fucking, uh,
Rockefeller estates.
I know,
but they got New Jersey license
plates. Therefore it must suck. Anyway,
let's get back to the
scapegoat. Um, so basically the,
uh,
you know,
the priest would take a day
off from dental and kids
and he'd lay his hands on a
farm animal and one would think he
would grab the horns and then start
fornicating. But this,
that's another story.
What they would do with the goat is
he'd lay his hands on it and he would
basically, somehow, I guess after
everybody confessed to this douche bag,
he would then place all of the sins on
the goat and then they would just banish
the goat and send it out of town with
all the sins in everybody's souls.
We're going to be clean again. But this
is the funny thing. As the goat left,
people would line up on either
side of the street and they would,
they would heckle the
goat and jeer at them. Eh,
you fucking adulterous piece of shit.
Yeah.
Why don't you jump off again?
You can't just yelling about
the sins that they did.
I don't know what it was. Yeah. It
keeps stealing from the pot at work.
You selfish prick,
yelling at a farm animal,
you know,
I swear to God,
I would love to have a segment on here
of all this stupid fucking things that,
that, that they do in religion
that people, you know.
Yeah,
there's no fucking way,
there wasn't somebody like me back
then go into it. This is fuck.
Why are we yelling at a goat?
You know?
I mean how you're banged somebody
fucking wife. You stole money from work,
you know,
you're booted an old lady in the ass.
Do you really think it's in the
goat now and it's just walking?
I just don't fucking get it. Even if they
filled your head up with it as a kid,
at some point you gotta be looking
at it like this is a fucking goat.
Okay.
It's got nothing to do with it.
So anyways,
they would just Jared this thing and
they'd send it out of town and then
everybody would be absolved and I
don't know where to go. It would go.
Sometimes they say they take the goat
and they would throw it off a cliff,
you know? I know it's extra painful
for me because I fucking love goats.
I really do.
I was actually feeding some this morning.
I don't know what it is about them.
I think they're fucking hilarious.
You know I got this buddy. He lives out
here, right? He's got this giant house,
there's all this fucking land
and he's got farm animals,
farm animals on it and I'm thinking he's
got these fucking things because he's
like me. He's, he likes, he thinks
goats or funny or whatever. And it is,
and I found out that there's tax laws
out that if you farm on your land,
you only have to pay
property taxes on one acre.
So he went out and got these goats.
He doesn't even give a shit about it.
Can you fucking believe that he's got
like 10 goddamn goats and he has to go out
there with this bucket of feed every day.
He's got to feed these things and it's
hard as an in it. That's what kills me.
It's just just pay.
It's just paid the taxes.
If I,
it would be worth it to not get up there
with that lunch pail of cheerios every
fucking morning.
Okay?
Jesus fucking Christ. What is what? It's
just money. It's paper. Who gives a fuck?
You just, you know, work a couple extra
hours. Fuck it. What do I owe you?
You sit down, you're writing
numbers on a piece of paper.
You stick it in a magic envelope. You'll
fucking lick it. You send it out next.
Jesus Christ are you gonna sit there
and have a bunch of goddamn livestock.
It's fucking guys swear to God.
Okay.
If, if, if you had a Giraffe, oh, what
do you guys want? What do you guys want?
Hang on. This is the hotel.
Yeah, sorry about that.
I had to go answer the phone.
I couldn't even figure out
how to work the fucking phone.
He's probably somebody above me
that was probably yelling too loud.
God knows what they are mad about.
Okay.
Anna, just thinking about some of
the Shit I've made fun of. You know,
Jesus beastiality and Bon Jovi
and they all hold the same
weight here in New Jersey. Um,
the hell was I talking about? Oh yeah.
This fucking guy. I swear to God, if he,
if he would get a giraffe, you
get like five giraffes. If,
if he only had to pay
like a quarter acre tax.
Okay.
They always amazes me when people
like that in the money, you know?
Okay.
I mean, I obviously give a fuck about
money. I want to have enough to survive.
But uh,
the amount of shit that didn't
work and I never took it back.
Okay.
Just blows my eye.
I've probably kept at least 25 grand worth
of shit that doesn't work in my life.
I just gotta you gotta be shitting
they same as what? The fucking prime.
He's fucking pieces of shit and I go off,
then my girl goes to last.
You return it. Ah, not doing that shit.
Standing down there with the sales slip,
like some angry old fucking lady.
I'm not doing it.
Who to hell would be calling me now
I'm all self conscious about whatever.
If I'm too loud, knock on
my door, I swear to God.
I bet it was the Bon
Jovi Shit. Um, anyway,
so let's get on with the podcast. This
is the Monday morning podcast. Everybody,
if you're to this podcast,
welcome. Um, this is yes,
and if you're thinking this is extra
dirty and extra angry this week, no,
this is how it is every fucking week.
All right. Do one of these every week.
I do them on Monday mornings because I
know most people hate their jobs or they
hate their commute. They hate their
spouse or they hate themselves,
you know, and they need,
they need to brake.
And it's also a great way to horror
out wherever the fuck I'm going to be.
Uh,
speaking of which I am
going to be in a Columbus,
Columbus, so Ohio at the funny
bone down at the mall. Dot.
Bragen on the, uh, September
9th, 10th and 11th.
That is my next gig. I'm gonna try
to go to that, uh, Ohio state game.
You know, it's in September. That's
always a dangerous one. You know,
to go to a college football game is
September. Who were they playing?
They playing Wentworth
technical institute.
You know,
I'm new to college football the last
couple of years and evidently that's what
they do.
They've got all their cupcake games in
the beginning of the year and I guess
these other colleges,
uh, they pay money to,
to play these giant teams and get
the living shit kicked out of them on
television just to,
I don't know what to expose to get TV
exposure for their school. I have no idea.
Speaking of scapegoats,
their entire fucking division three team
goes out there a bunch of up against a
bunch of roided up division one guys
or whatever the fuck they're doing now.
I don't know. And then they get the shit
kicked out of him, but I don't know,
every once in a while an
Appalachian Mountain state
community college will beat a Michigan.
So I don't know who they're playing that
weekend, but I'm going to go down there.
Uh,
I was looking forward to it until I spent
fucking 14 straight days on the road.
But, uh, anyways, the podcast.
Um, anyways, if you want it,
if you wanted me to read any emails, any
questions you have in a year, underrated,
overrated a,
send them to bill@themmpodcast.com.
If you'd like to follow
along on the podcast,
go to www.themmpodcast.com.
Now a lot of you guys keep just
typing in m m podcast.com and like,
what the fuck?
I can't find it.
It's the m M podcast.com like
the Ohio State University.
Okay. That's what it is. That's where
all the youtube videos videos are.
That's where you can contact
me and all of that stuff.
We have a donation button
if you'd like to, um,
donate any sorta money
towards the podcast, we'd
greatly appreciate it. And uh,
we also have,
uh,
the podcast select and this is where
I interview interesting people.
I've only done one of them,
but I like to speak of them as if
it's a giant library. I got one.
The 99 cents is a great
to contribute 99 cents.
Andy gets something if you want to
listen to NFL football star, right?
Tackle Ephraim Salaam.
Talk about trying to rip
somebodies voicebox out as they,
as the guy tried to fucking break his arm,
that interview was there and a,
I will be doing Monday morning podcast
selects as I meet interesting guests.
That's how I'm doing them. All right. When
somebody, uh, somebody different. Okay.
Because,
uh,
I don't want to interview other comedians.
I just feel too many
podcasts or doing that.
I've done too many podcasts
talking about comedy.
I don't have any comedy stories left.
I really don't.
And I gotta be honest with you,
aside from a couple of
people who are really good
interviewers, the Mark Marin's,
Joe Rogan's and that type of shit,
uh,
I probably should have
saved most of them for, ah,
the unmasked that I did
okay.
With, uh, Ron from Ron and Fez,
I dunno where you can find that,
but I did one of those
this past week and, uh, ah,
I've just been running my yap
all fucking week late. Why don't,
why don't we get to something entertaining
here? Uh, somebody sent me a, um,
this youtube video of this week,
you really have to watch it. Okay.
It's one of those shows. It's
basically, it's a rip off of the view.
It's for broad sitting around and
they got the same thing. You know,
they got the older one,
they got the sexy one,
they got the one who was fat and then got
her fucking stomach tied up like a God
damn balloon. Not now she's dropping
weight faster than a junkie. Right.
I don't even know if that's true. I
just looked around them. You know,
they got the racially mixed chick and
they all got on their fucking shoes.
Right. The little outfits. Uh,
hang on a second. Hang on a second.
Somebody's knocking. I'll let
you know what this is. All right.
You guys not going to believe this shit
that was security and they just said
that they had a noise complaint.
There was a lot of, uh,
the guy comes to the, I
go to the door. Right?
This is so pathetic that at 43,
I'm getting reprimanded.
I feel like I'm in fucking high
school and I talk like it too. Um,
let me just the levels here or maybe
turn up yours cause I don't want to get
kicked out of here.
Um,
and say open a door and there's a
security guard. And he goes, Ah, you Ben?
And I'm like,
no.
Okay.
Cause I know he, I know that he knows
my name's bill. Well this is the thing,
when security interrogates you,
you never offer any information,
you know,
are you bent? No. And then
I just looked at him like,
is there anything else I can
help you with? And he's like,
and he looks down on a piece of paper.
Oh, are you bill? And I was like,
yes, yes I am. And he
goes, uh, yeah, we, uh,
we get a noise complaint from
people on either side of you.
Uh, these are VIP rooms on either side
of you. And, uh, talking about, uh,
it's very loud. There's a
lot of cursing. And I'm like,
all right. He goes, is there anyone
else? No. Wait, wait, wait. He told me,
can you step out in the hall?
And I go for what? He goes,
I need you to step out in the hall.
And I said for what?
And then he just goes into a Spiel,
you know the fuck the want you to step
out in the hall for [inaudible] am I
gonna be able to hear you better?
You know I sit in the racking
like your Goddamn state trooper,
you're fucking sport coat on. It has
the name of the hotel and the lapel.
I'm supposed to step out in the hall.
I don't know who you are. Right?
I'm such a Dick. It's ridiculous. Right?
So I made them basically say I just
didn't doorway and he asked me, he goes,
is there anybody else in there?
And I was like no. And then yeah,
that's what he basically said.
I'm being too loud.
Jesus Christ. I was cursing, I think
it was you realized that he said this,
people on either side trying to sleep
and I was singing Bon Jovi songs at the
top of my fucking lungs.
All right.
I was also talking about beastiality
and I was trashing Jesus.
You know what? This hotel is cool as hell
cause when you really think about it,
they probably should have
kicked me out. Um, all right,
so this is going to be my voice for the
rest. This is bill on punishment voice.
I'd like to apologize to everybody
here at the Sheridan. Um,
anyways,
you know what some rich cons on the other
side of the door with a fucking piece
of one of those really fancy glasses
that they think came from France but
actually came from a fucking pottery
barn. Um, if you can hear me,
go fuck yourself. This is what you
get for nuke in the economy. Um,
all right. So anyways, so
I'm watching this show, these
four fucking broads on it.
Okay. Listen, nothing too. I had
to be, oh, he told me this is,
this is your one and only
warning next time you will be.
And he say objected from the hotel.
He had such hacky security,
uh,
like terminology, you
know, a fucking enough.
I do,
you know how bad I just want to yell
cunt at the top of my lungs right now and
get ejected from the fucking hotel.
Just so I can get out of Jersey.
Maybe I should call up Paul version.
Tell me to, you know, fuck that.
That's what I'm going to
do after this podcast.
I'm calling up Paul Versey and I'm having
them coming down and get me all right.
You know, fucking threaten me next time I
come up here. What do you my fucking Dad
fucking douchebag Christ. I swear to God.
You know what's funny about
the male voice is it, uh,
is it carries,
you ever noticed that
when there's a couple next door,
you can never, the woman's voice,
you're just hear the guy every
once in a while go, Ooh, the Lulu.
Whoo, whoo, whoo. Yeah.
You never hit the broad. So
I'm probably gonna get kicked out.
Okay,
what do I do? And you know
what? Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll take a cab back to New York.
Yeah.
Then they drop courses.
They probably won't show up
because they're still afraid.
Afraid of the weather channel. Um,
anyway, so these four fucking broads,
they're on TV,
right.
And they ended up there talking
about that guy that doing that story.
You know that story where that
dude get his dick cut off.
I'm gonna have to raise the levels here.
There we go. How's that? Is that better?
All right. So talking about that
guy who got his dick cut off
his wife, drugged him, tied him to a bed,
cut his dick off, threw it in a
garbage disposal and turned it on.
And it was basically because
he wanted to get a divorce from her.
She mutilated them.
She ended the guy's fucking
life and he saw of quality.
Life is over and these women are
talking about it and lo and behold,
it's fucking hilarious to them.
They had all they could do to keep a
straight face during the first minute of
setting up the story.
And then all the jokes come and they
are laughing their fucking asses off.
It's the funniest fucking thing ever.
And this right here,
it's because of that type of shit that
I don't feel that I am misogynistic.
I just don't.
I think that I am just like women.
I trashed women the way they trash guys.
It's just nobody pays attention
to the broads. They don't.
Do you think of a guy mutilated a woman
in any shape or form that four guys on a
pregame NFL show would be
laughing about it? You know,
Sharon Osborne was the guest and she goes,
somebody asks,
you think the guy deserved, and she goes,
well, it depends on what he did. You know?
I mean,
that thought is totally overlaps.
The thought of those morons in the
Middle East who cut women's clits off,
you know,
it's fucking medieval thought
and it's just considered silly.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know.
But it maintains what
I've always fucking said,
that women will do a to you exactly what
they don't want you to do to them if
you let them.
And I think why so many guys are miserable
in marriages is they get married to
fucking young before they really know
how to stick up for themselves in a
relationship. And that's why
before you know it, yeah,
married and all your shit is either in
the basement of the garage and she's
barely touching it and a,
and you're wondering what the fuck
happened to your life. You know,
I don't know.
The video is,
is going to be up on the [inaudible]
podcast.com. You know something.
This is actually,
I like this talking like this.
This is very challenging to try and
be funny with a late night DJ voice.
All right. This next chunk of the
podcast goes out to the ladies. Ladies,
if you're out there and you're single,
hang in there,
there's a date rape is on the horizon.
This next song rape me by
Nirvana. Who was, I'll tell you.
Um,
I know that somebody,
some Vanderbilt on either side to
may going Keith curse thing again.
MMM. Anyways, uh, being on the road,
what did I want to talk about?
Bitches laughing at Dick being
cut off already talked about that,
wanting to go home. Talked about
that. All right. Last week, uh,
I was,
I,
we showed that youtube clip about that
guy running on that soccer field and
getting, uh, you know,
getting beat down by the cops and then
the crowd overwhelms the cops and beats
down the cops.
And I wanted to hear from the police
officers to just ask basically why they're
such dicks when they pull you over.
Uh, not in a judgmental way, but just,
I'm just basically asking the question,
the way all drivers talk.
So we have a cop responding here. He
says, hey bill, not all cops are assholes.
Some are just lazy. Uh, the summer
after my sophomore year, oh, no, no, no,
no. This is a different ones. What
the fuck is the one from the cop?
That's the one I want to hit. Oh,
here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
Let's see if I can read this before
being ejected from the hotel. Uh,
you're not going to be,
the worst is if I do get ejected.
This guy's going to be standing here,
uh,
with this security fucking
jacket on in my hotel room,
watching me gather my things.
So once again,
I already have a game plan for that.
If I come,
if there's another knock at my door,
I'm not opening it.
I'm going to look through the peephole
and I'm talking through the door.
So we opened the door please.
And I'm going to go, why?
Uh, uh, cause and I'm just
going to ask him straight out.
Am I being ejected from
the hotel? Uh, yes sir.
You need to let me know and I'll just
bolt the door and I'm going to be like,
listen, I'm going to gather my things.
I'll be out there in five minutes.
You just sit tight.
All right.
You with no fucking badge.
What are you going to do? Take off your
shoe? Is that what you're going to do?
Try and throw it through the crack
in the door. It's not going to hit me
fucking asshole. Can you step out into
the lobby until the hallway please
go fuck yourself.
Huh?
You fucking half a cop?
You half a security guard?
Like step out into the hotel? No, I won't.
Okay, then I'll just, just
stay there then you douchebag.
Um, anyways, let's plow
ahead. So here's a cup. Uh,
um, okay, Bill. Uh,
the thing about this job is basically
that we have no fucking idea who we are
dealing with at any given time. Just
because someone looks sweet and innocent.
And just because the situation
isn't likely to escalate,
it doesn't mean that they're not capable
of murder or that the situation may go
pear shaped quickly.
I don't even know what that means.
Okay.
Pear shaped, I don't want to
shape is a pair of shaped like
what, what, what shape is it before it
goes pear shaped? Is it an apple shape?
Somebody he can't talk shop
cause you're gonna lose me.
I'm not that bright a guy. Um, anyways,
I can't tell you how many times
that someone said to me like,
I'm going to do anything people or what
about that person running upstairs? Hi,
can you eject that eight, eight year
old out of the fucking hotel. All right.
You know, I feel, I feel
like right now like, uh,
okay.
Either I'm announcing a golf match or,
um,
okay.
Um, I'm reporting live from
a hostage situation. Okay.
There talking to him right now,
he still has the weapon
up to the woman's head.
You can clearly see that
she's frightening. Okay.
There's somebody flanking him on the left.
Oh, he doesn't like, okay, he's fired.
A shot it missed. And Al, they
just took them down. Oh my God.
He's been shot in the head
and they have to woman. Um,
anyways, plowing ahead
here. Um, so anyways,
the amount of time just got pulls people
over and the person behind the wheel
says like, I'm going to do anything.
People think that I know. Oh,
the people,
the drivers and stuff think that I know
them their whole lives and know that
their Cape, that they're incapable
of harming anyone. But I don't,
I always think back to the academy and
all the videos we watched of cops getting
killed or nearly killed because they
made one mistake or had a lapse in the
paranoia that keeps us
safe. See that? I knew it.
I knew it was something that they
showed them at the academy. I said,
another thing to remember is that there
is a gun at every call and every traffic
stop the gun on my belt.
No Man is invincible and a lucky
punch can knock me unconscious,
leaving me vulnerable to take to them
taking my weapon and killing me or others.
For this reason,
we like to keep some distance.
We don't like to be touched in a bubble.
We can't allow people to get the
opportunity to take control of our weapon.
Um, so when someone's sir, uh, squarely
or not listening to my commands,
they may get cuffed and put in the back
of my car until everything is figured
out. They may not like it, but I am
going home at the end of my shift,
not to the morgue. Uh, that
leaves another point of control.
No one likes to be bossed
around and told what to do.
But when the police are there,
were there for a reason someone called
us or we have a reason to believe that
we're needed. Once we're there, we have
to be in control. We call the shots, not,
um,
not forgo or to be on a power trip,
but because if we lose control,
we're fucked. It's our ass.
If someone gets hurt and our president,
and it's literally Rs,
if we get hurt or killed,
if someone thinks that they can
do what they want or walk over me,
how am I supposed to do my job? Uh,
as for the videos you recently posted,
those cops with the name changer
were absolutely terrible.
If there is a lawful warrant for
that guys arrest despite the reason,
uh, it is their job to arrest him. Um,
the suspect knew about the warrant.
I didn't know what video is.
It didn't take care of it. Now he
asked to see a judge they should have,
they should have used much more
forced to take them into custody.
But the reality of it is you can't just
be able to keep passively resisting a
cop until, until the cops let you
go. Uh, they can't let you go.
All right, here we go. With the
video at the stadium was disturbing.
They shouldn't have been. Obviously
jabbing the guy with their batons,
but they had the right
to take him into custody.
People running around sports fields
isn't and shouldn't be tolerated.
Are they supposed to stop the game and
wait for him to be finished with running
around?
What if he assaulted or killed an athlete?
Then everyone would be crying
that the cops didn't do anything.
There's a great point.
Also when we deal with people,
90% of the possible danger
from them is their hands.
If you're laying on your hands and I
can't see them, I will expect the worst.
How am I supposed to do?
How am I supposed to know what they are?
Lay that they aren't laying on a weapon.
Uh,
when I want your hand gimme your hand or
I will use force to get them out. Yeah,
they go, uh, one last thing is tasers. Uh,
they are amazing tools. I've been
tased and training and yes, it sucks,
but it beats getting thumped or
shot. Uh, we're in the old days,
a guy may get the crap beat out
of him or his brain can cost.
Now he gets an electric
ride for five seconds.
It's also amazing because the suspect
can be cuffed while being taste.
Basically less chance for everyone to see,
to get seriously hurt.
Why should I risk getting seriously hurt
or killed going hands on with someone
when they can just be taste. Um, that,
you know what somebody told me a
long time ago, if you want to make,
if you get pulled over by a cop,
a great way to help them relax and maybe
bring down them being a dick to you is
a have your hands where they can see them.
You know,
if it's during the day, I always put
on like right on the steering wheel.
I get pulled over a lot by
the way. Uh, not as much. I
guess back in the day I did,
cause I used to just drive 80 miles an
hour anywhere I was going, you know,
there's only so many fucking
farm she can look at. Um,
it was funny. So I'm still nervous
about getting thrown out of here.
And the only reason why is because some
of the roads are washed out and I don't
know where the fuck I would go by.
I don't know why I'm nervous because
I am now speaking in a speaking tone.
If I'm not allowed to speak,
this is actually great stuff. What if
I show the hotel security my hands,
maybe he'll allow me to stay.
So anyways,
um,
okay.
Yeah, I put my hands right on top of the
steering wheel where they can see them.
Um,
if it's a sunny day,
I have one hanging out the car
window where they can see it.
And the other one I just put on top of
my head, like an ape chilling out in, uh,
in the zoo.
You know,
when they sit there and they just have
that one arm draped over their head,
uh,
I sit like that.
And then when they show up, I just had
my hands on the steering wheel and, uh,
and you know what,
there's still assholes,
you know, it's kind of a
crap shoot, you know, so,
but I think this guy run
up a lot of great points.
What the fuck is he supposed to do?
And that's a great point.
If the guy ran on the field and
did something to an athlete,
then they would blame the security and
they would be screaming and yelling at
them,
you know,
which probably goes back to the weather
channel then if they don't scare the
living shit out of people that they
would get blamed for not warning people.
But I think it has more to do with, uh,
scaring people, gives them great ratings.
Um, so I don't know any
more cops want to weigh in.
I, here's one for you. I want to know
what, what do you guys think about that?
You can anonymously
talk about this as cops,
that kid who got shot on
the subway platform and died
new year's Day in Oakland,
um, they do definitely
wasn't being compliant. He
definitely wasn't giving them,
showing them his hands. And this guy, I
dunno, he's like the Manchurian candidate.
All of a sudden the guy said the wrong
thing. The guy's laying on his stomach.
Okay.
One cops got his foot on his
neck. I mean, the dude is down.
And all of a sudden this
one kid just stood up,
takes out a gun and just shoots the
guy right in the back. And I do,
it's like what the fuck is shot me?
And he ended up dying.
Um,
you know
what about that one?
That's, that's, that's one,
this is what I should say for the podcast.
So like,
cause that's what I want to ask and I
didn't want to like just have so many go
on there anonymously and just say what
you think about it should have that cop
gone to jail because uh,
he got what basically usually happens
when a cop shoots somebody is he got off?
Um, I dunno, but
I don't want to, I don't want to do
this whole cop thing attack and cops,
I'd like to try to create some sort of
forum where you can actually anonymously
present your side and that worry about
pissing off other cops or worry about
pissing off victims or any of that type
of shit. Cause I think it's, I don't know,
it's one of those things for
some reason I guess I know why.
The reason is it's too much shit at
stake so people don't talk about it. Um,
that could have been a lot more fun topic.
I didn't have to speak
in my time out voice.
This is officially the first Mlm podcast.
Timeout on. Oh wait a minute then.
Fucking old bastard downstairs.
Yeah.
You know something?
I think I'm allowed asshole.
Okay.
I think that that's what it is. You
know, on both sides of the country.
I've been told that I'm too loud.
I need to shut the fuck up self.
They know at some point you gotta look
in the mirror and realize that you,
all right, let's plow ahead of here.
All right. Advice for the week.
They'll have known this young lady for
a few years and we're very fond of each
other. Uh, but she has had, she's had,
she has a possessive boyfriend with a
stupid haircut in a couple of times when
she's broken up with him,
she's come to me. Uh,
but then she goes back to macro man.
Uh, this is the thing that bothers me.
Whenever things have got
gotten sexual between us,
like I go down on her
and blower fucking mind.
This guy has definitely got confidence.
He goes, she never returns the favor.
She gets disgusted.
She even gets disgusted.
If I sulk in my seat that I didn't
get any dude sulking is like,
I don't, I'm not gonna sit here and
act like I know what turns women on.
But I can tell you the exact
opposite of turning a woman on.
If you want to have the exact opposite,
Spanish fly would be sulking.
Nothing makes a pussy dry up like sulking.
Just let you know right there. Okay. Um,
but nothing that makes it wetter with
complete indifference. Um, anyways,
once she said callously Oh,
after she did,
after the guy went down to her and
then she, he didn't get a blow job.
She wants callously said,
have a blank to alleviate my horniness
after having her completely naked on my
chair worshiping her and
pleasuring her holes,
Jesus Christ body.
Thank God I'm that yelling.
That one right there where
it kicked me out. Uh,
it was just me with the Styrofoam Cup.
Another time when we had intercourse,
we were drunk.
She stopped me halfway through and
she even stopped halfway through,
uh,
shit doing you a favor hand job.
She's never made me come.
These are the only examples of
when she tried to get me off.
And I'm a good looking chappy,
so it's not that.
Recently I boycotted her body.
I said,
let's be friends to be strictly platonic.
I won't even play with her.
NORCS I'm guessing her
titties. Uh, this is,
this has had the result of her trying
to rekindle things like the old magic.
Um, if she's not that into me, what the
fuck is going on? I'm finished with her.
But any insights you can give is a
treasure. All right? First of all, dude,
you're not finished with her.
Um,
just halfway through writing that you
probably realized what a PSAP you were
being. All right. Okay. First of
all, who's couldn't? Who you're,
you're fucking with the
psycho. All right. And, uh,
I don't know if this is a very, this is a
very touchy one to talk about here, but,
um,
this girl strikes me is one of those
girls who wants to be put in her place and
wants to be bent over something and once
a guy to tell her what the fuck is what?
All right, okay. Consensually.
Do you understand what I mean?
Okay. Don't take this the wrong way.
Going and just fucking give him a
forearm. Give her a forearm shiver. Right.
I'm not saying to do
that. All right. You know,
some girls that concert and they
know their account and they want to,
got to basically tell them that
they, it, it could be this,
I have no idea,
but I could tell you one thing right now,
sulking and keep coming back for more.
You like Charlie Brown,
she keeps pulling the football and uh,
you know,
if you want to fuck this girl,
walk away from her,
stop returning your phone calls
and all that type of shit. You,
you basically started to do that when
you boycotted a body. But then you said,
let's be friends. That's
a weak move. Okay.
What's this girl I think wants to
see you be a fucking man. All right.
And you're not,
you're going down on her.
You're pleasing her and
she's doing everything.
Everything she can to disrespect
you and you're allowing it.
MMM.
And I think that's turning on off. And I
think she's a fucking statistics psycho.
So she's getting you off as she's
leaving you with blue balls, you know,
I don't know.
That might be it.
Or she might be fucking angry at something
else and she's taken it out on you.
All I now do is walk away from this girl.
Just walk away from our birth.
Some fucking reason. You still want to
bang her one more time. Blow her off,
blow off her texts in or calls
for like a week and a half,
and then randomly answer one.
And when you pick up the phone,
just just have a whatever vibe. Hey,
what's going on? And I being me to,
to make calls and me, I to make
takes and been busy. What's up?
You want to hang out now?
Why not? Yeah. You know,
I dunno. What do we want to
handle you for and get blue balls.
You know, you fucking selfish.
You're fucking annoying.
Leave me alone.
You know I was probably too
angry but I'm sorry guys.
I'm fucking angry right now that
I have to talk like this. Yeah,
just blow her off and just be, you
know, and when you go to meet her,
meet her in a public place, don't go
over a place where she can immediately,
she's going to dress extra sexy when you
come over there cause she's trying to
get that power over you again.
Meet her in a fucking pop place and be
talking to her as you kind of glancing
around the room,
you know?
So what I hit on another girl while
she's standing there, I'm telling you
it out and when she asked you
to go home with their, don't
just say I'm cool or whatever,
you know,
fucking blow her off and if she ever
calls you again, she wants to cook,
hang out or whatever,
tell titled to come over to your place.
And the second she starts acting like
a Douche, kick her out. I don't know.
I had shit. It's what sucks about
a girl like that as immediately.
You got to try and get into her head.
Then you got to start playing games.
It's not worth it. There's, there's too
many decent girls out there who will,
when they take the dick out, they will
fucking complete whatever you want.
So I would just walk away from her.
MMM.
Let's be friends, Jesus Christ, body
that and sulking you need to take.
Those are the two parts of your game.
You need to work on this off season.
All right? And then maybe next
year you'll get the ring. Okay.
Good luck. All right, next one.
Bill. I'm a cubicle dwelling,
suffocated engineer in Texas.
I was rushed through the college
machine with all the rest of the cattle
destined to find a job,
don some pleated Khakis and live the rest,
live the rest of our lives and has
steadily paid servitude of the man.
But a few years ago out of college,
uh Oh,
but a few years ago out
of college and I hated,
I think you saying I'm a few years
out of college and I hate it. Uh,
I wish I'd followed my desire
to be some sort of a writer.
And after listening to your podcast among
others and hearing from friends that I
should have, I wish I'd given stand
up a shot. Well, now I'm 30 years old,
staring down the barrel of 35 more
years as a cozy smug engineer,
making six figures, but hating five
out of every seven days of my life.
I don't have any wife or kids,
but I feel like I'm too old to jump
back into being a starving artist.
What do I do?
Ah,
this is on you.
All right?
I would never tell somebody who's got a
six figure paying job to jump into this
fucking awful business. All right? Um,
but I would never tell you not to do it.
All I got to tell you is you can't
half ass getting into this business,
all right? Or you are going to be,
you think you hate in your life. Now,
uh, just picture hating five
out of every seven days,
except you're making fucking,
you're making low five figures and you're
old now and nobody wants to fucking
book here. And you don't have any wife
and kids, I'm telling you. All right,
I'll give you this advice. If you
decide to become a fucking comedian,
there's no turning back. All
right? And you got to go into it.
You can't even consider quitting.
And it has nothing to do with fucking
talent and has to do with desire.
I'm telling you. Um,
that's what I would say.
So what I would do if I was you,
I would keep my six figure job and
I'd start doing some open mics.
That's what I would do.
All right?
And if you feel in your heart is you're
standing on stage that this is what the
fuck you want to do with your life.
I would do it in a second
because six figures, seven
figures. If you're miserable,
it's not going to be worth it.
All right?
But I don't know if you
know you're into comedy,
you know, the way I'm into playing
drums, drums, or a hobby for me,
I absolutely fucking love them.
But there's no fucking way I would have
always about to climb into a van with
three other fucking guys,
you know? And he pasta,
I'm not going to do it. It just, I dunno.
I actually played drums and
I realized I didn't have it.
You know, I didn't, I didn't have it as
a musician and I didn't have that drive.
Um, but when I got on stage,
the first time I did comedy,
I just, I never looked back and I was
just like, this is, I'm doing this shit.
So, um, they go,
so you have to answer those questions.
So the best way to do it is
to sign up for some open mics.
I see how it goes and see how you feel.
And like I said,
if you feel like that's what
you want to do, then I would,
I would work towards it, but I would
not quit that six figure paying job. Uh,
you don't just quit your fucking job.
You don't build up your time so you can
swing out of that job into some fucking
paid gigs. That's how I did it. Um,
I kept my day job until I moved to New
York City and I had saved up a bunch of
money. Um, you know, I
had paid off all my bills,
I didn't have a car payment,
I had nothing.
And I moved to New York and I had a
nest egg of fucking money. And, uh,
and yeah, I've told these stories
before. I hate fucking spaghetti.
Every God damn night,
three pieces of bread filled up my stomach
and I just did stand up every night and
I just did. I just wasn't doing standup.
I was working towards
getting better at it,
analyzing what I was doing wrong and um,
you know, but I would, I would
never tell you to quit your job.
And I would also never tell you that you
can't start comedy at 30 years of age
because you can't. All
right, so there it is,
but at the ball's in your fucking court.
All right. Youtube videos of the week.
Uh, we had an earthquake
here, um, this past week. Uh,
best earthquake reaction.
This is hilarious.
It's like three guys on the MLB network
or something like talking about baseball
and all of a sudden the hurricane comes.
Uh,
it's fucking hilarious because people
on the east coast don't know what an
earthquake feels like a, so they're
sort of looking around like, um,
wait a second. Is anybody else
feeling something moving? Uh,
in defense of them? I was one
of those little shaken ones. Um,
somebody sent some home videos
of Peyton manning as a kid, uh,
running around whining or whatever. But,
uh, I, I'm too hard on Peyton manning.
He gets fucking ridiculous
how hard I am on this guy.
But everybody wind is a kid, but at this
still funny as a patriots fan to watch.
Um,
and here's two that I got.
Um, it's called fuck, fuck the
police one. And this is hilarious.
This is some guy,
I dunno if he's in Brooklyn or what,
this black dude who knows his rights
has been harassed by the police.
You can tell his entire life or whatever,
but he's screaming at the cops.
That's the mistake he makes.
They don't arrest him, but the shit
he's saying, if he would just say it,
if he just said it, I think he would
have been fine, but he's screaming it.
Uh,
and it's really funny.
It's actually the sky goes
on for like 20 minutes.
And, uh, I've said before,
it's all about not losing your
shit and this guy loses his shit.
But I don't think he ever gets arrested,
but it's fucking hilarious. Um,
and he has a youtube video of the week.
This was actually suggested
by Paul Versey, uh,
Oh will forte. And this is a,
a sketch with Peyton manning.
Peyton manning is fucking
hilarious in the sketch. Um,
it's basically will forte,
you know,
everybody comes walking in there like
a basketball team and they're getting
their asses kicked and will forte comes
in and basically tells people that they
shouldn't quit and that he had a coach
and they played him the song one time
when his team was down by 60 points and
by listening to the song and amp them
all the way up.
And then he basically puts on some
fucking song from the 1930s and starts
dancing to it. And it's fucking
hilarious. Underrated for the week.
Will Forte guy is, is
fucking hilarious. And uh,
please watch the director's cut of
macgruber highly recommended that.
And what else do we got here?
We got the a woman cuts.
Guy's Dick off all the four.
Brad's laughing at that.
And I got one other one here. What the
fuck is it? Hang on, hang on, hang on.
Um,
I'm the worst.
The fuck did it go? All right.
Oh wait, don't say it too
loud. Don't curse too loud.
We will eject you from
the Sheridan. Um, oh.
Future gun owner.
I'll creepy game show host.
There's another one that we have.
Creepy fucking game show host.
She used to see this.
I can't believe that this guy actually
was allowed on air and I showed it to
Bobby Kelly and he was laughing
at just this guy's fucking,
the game show was basically a mother
and a daughter. You know something.
They already showed this on tosh point.
Oh,
I really try not to do that because
I figured everybody sees him,
but we'll put it up there just in case.
But Bobby Kelly actually
showed me another one.
I don't know where the fuck this took
place. It sounds like it's in Scandinavia.
And this guy calls this kid up to sing
a song and he basically just starts
kissing his back. It's
unbelievably disgusting. Uh,
nibbling on his ear in the back of
his hair is this kid is singing.
It's fucking brutal.
Um, alright. Overrated.
Underrated for the weekend. Then I'm
going to fucking rap this pie. Holy Shit.
Hour and 15 minutes. Time flies when
you're whispering in a super eight, um,
overrated hand sanitizer.
I've been sharing the company restaurant
with a bunch of coworkers who believe
using hand sanitizer is the equivalent
or even superior to washing their hands
with good old soap and water.
It's not the rubbing alcohol and the
hand sanitizer kills the bacteria and
destroys virus presence on the hand.
And that's about it.
It does not physically remove the genital
grime deposited on the hands after guy
has finished jiggling his junk to
get rid of the last drops of pests.
These people also use other commodities
such as the company refrigerator,
therefore effectively covering every God
damn thing that they touch with their
dead penis and vagina
cells. All right, that guy,
he's not short of descriptive adjectives,
a overrated lawns.
People dump all kinds of chemicals
to make them look pretty. Personally,
I prefer a clean water over a pretty
long, uh, overrated. The overnight,
the other night I decided to have a
nice wink and crash out for the night.
So I hop on the generic porn site and
started browsing. Next thing I know,
two hours have passed,
I was still awake,
hadn't ranked and barely even
had a Fleetwood Mac, soft rock,
half Chubb, et Cetera. Uh, I
didn't even watch a full video,
which I think no one really does
total fucking waste. Instead,
I just use the girl's section of a
Hurley catalog I had laying around,
which worked pretty well just
so we all know. All right.
Underrated paper.
Grocery bags,
plastic bags are given to you by default
at all the grocery stores I've been to.
They should give you paper and if you want
plastic, he should have to ask for it.
Uh, all right. This ends the, uh, comedy,
the Monday first Monday morning podcast,
comedy timeout.
And I feel lucky because I did
get injected from the hotel.
Um, that's it. I hope you enjoyed
this weird ass fucking podcast.
This podcast was like a nirvana song
started off loud. Then it got quiet,
but never got loud again. Um, so I
guess it isn't, it's like the first,
now feels shut the fuck up. All right. Go
fuck yourselves. That's the podcast. Sia.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].